foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
gays please report to the principal's
office yes that's you guys
tonight is our night we're getting into
the couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you
get that Isabelle what would I say hey
girl how's your boyfriend how's his
penis
[Music]
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
we were just practicing for a
self-defense club like a Fight Club yes
just stay in your lane into your
munching Beaver Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
you can be our club advisor no my mom
did say I need to pick up a hobby
Club
[Applause]
I have a safe space like this it means a
lot to people I'm gonna finally reverse
stalk my stalker yeah I'll be able to
kill my stepdad awesome that seems so
supportive of women especially the hot
ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me no I literally
saw you yesterday so nerd I [__] your
mom
we are literally at the bottom you have
nowhere to cope it up
your clock is over
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how [__] cool they are
fun places
I know y'all ain't tickling the Pearl I
just don't know if you're supposed to be
talking to us like that just like as a
teacher
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]